يعلن اعتزاله كره القدم تشاد جي بي تي
يحدد الافضل في تاريخ دوري الابطال وبايرن
ميونخ يكشف عن قميصه للموسم المقبل هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
كشف قائد يوفنتوس الايطالي ليوناردو
بونوتشي عن اعتزاله لعب كره القدم بعد
نهايه الموسم المقبل اللاعب الذي خاض اكثر
من 500 مباراه مع اليوفي قرر ترك ملاعب
كره القدم بعد انتهاء العقد الذي يربطه مع
النادي الايطالي مسيره برج الاحترافيه
بدات قبل 18 عاما توجد خلالها بالعديد من
الالقاب المحليه مع نادي الشمال الايطالي
نبقى مع اخبار نادي يوفنتوس والاصابه
المتجدده لنجمعه الفرنسي كان قد اصيب قبل
نحو عام كامل مع ناديها السابق مانشستر
يونايتد ولم ينتظم الى الان مع الفريق
الايطالي وبالنظر لمشاركته القليله مع
النادي بان كل دقيقه لعبها بوجبا كلفت
اداره يوفي نحو 60 الف يورو مهابه عشره
ملايين يورو للموسم صافي من الضرائب
برنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي اقتحم عالم كره
القدم واختار بنفسه التشكيله المثاليه في
تاريخ دوري الابطال التشكيله المثاليه لم
تشهد وجود نجوم الماضي خط الهجوم ضمه
بنزيما ميسي وكريستيانو فيما سيطرت ثنائي
البارصا تشافي وان يستعل خط الوسط
بالاضافه الى زيدان كانما اختار تشاد جي
بي تي نوير لحراسه المرمى ومعه كافو
بيكنباور مالديني وربرت وكارلوس في خط
الدفاع
في خبرنا الاخير كشف نادي بايرن ميونخ عن
قميصه الجديد الذي طغى عليه اللون الابيض
مع خطوط حمراء وهي الالوان التقليديه
للفريق البافاري وتحتوي القمصان الجديد
على التكنولوجيا تساعد على القاء اجساد
اللاعبين بارده خلال المباريات التي تقام
في درجه في درجه حراره عاليه كما سيكون
القميص متاحا على المتجر الالكتروني
للنادي بدءا من تاريخ اليوم